JONATHAN KELLER: Thank you
all for joining me today.
My name is Jonathan
Keller, and I
have the privilege
of being the Director
of Product Management
for the BigQuery team
here at Google Cloud.
Very excited to
have the opportunity
to walk you through a
lot of the innovations
that we're working on
to help you unlock value
from your data.
It's no secret why
we're all here.
The world has become
much more data-driven,
and every company
and every industry
is on their journey to figure
out how to leverage data
to drive value.
Unfortunately though,
many companies
are still struggling to
realize tangible and measurable
value from their
data, but they want
to learn how to provide
better customer experiences
or drive operational
excellence through more
intelligent decision making
and improve processes.
Happy to be here to share with
you many of the innovations
that BigQuery is working on to
help customers around the world
finally be able to untap
the power of their data.
If you're not familiar
with BigQuery,
it is Google's cloud-scale
enterprise data warehouse.
It sits at the center of
our open platform strategy
that delivers value from data.
And of course,
standard SQL with DML.
It's truly serverless,
multitenant, encrypted,
durable, and ready for the
largest internet scale services
and also highly secure
enterprise workloads
from gigabytes to exabytes.
It is also intelligent, with
built in ML, extensibility,
and support for
in-memory analytics.
It has a simplified
architecture that
unifies real time
and batch workloads
and supports virtually unlimited
number of analytics use cases.
And it does this all with
industry-leading reliability
and predictable costs.
Just to drill into a
little bit of how Google
is able to uniquely
deliver this value,
BigQuery takes advantage of
Google's full stack innovations
from hardware and
storages, network,
all the way up to
the software that
has been used to analyze data
for search and advertising
for over a decade.
We are not strangers
to big data analytics.
This full stack
approach allows you
to access stateless
compute, which
enables virtually unlimited
capacity to analyze your data.
There's no dedicated
VMs and no clusters
for you to worry about,
think about sizing,
or trying to manage.
Our unique network and
storage infrastructure
provides incredibly
high throughput,
making it easy for BigQuery
to analyze exabytes
of customer data every
day and support streaming
ingestion of petabytes
of data every day,
as well, all while providing
industry-leading reliability.
And now with the recent
natively-integrated BI engine,
we're leveraging this
amazing full stack to power
in memory and real time
analytics, as well.
I wish I had more time to
walk you through everything
we are working on to provide
an innovation pace that
supports your business.
But unfortunately
I just have time
to call out a few things from
the huge number of capabilities
that have been released
over the last few months.
So whether it's
governance capabilities
like our field-level
encryption, our automatic DLP
integration with BigQuery which
helps you secure your data
or continue to invest in
advancing in data warehouse,
machine learning with BQML,
or powerful new SQL workload
management capabilities,
we're committed
to meeting your analytics needs.
With that quick recap of
where we've been investing,
I want to pivot to a
deep dive in the areas
investment we're making to
really support your business
building and running
applications in the Cloud,
such as interoperability
support that breaks down
data and application silos,
our migration and management
support for helping
you get to the Cloud
and save money when
you're here, and finally,
a ton of investments in cracking
that hard problem of really
getting value from
data with real time
and predictive analytics.
As we think about
BigQuery's interoperability,
it's really not like any
other data warehouse.
You get choice of storage,
cloud, tools, engines,
and languages, and we make
that possible to leverage
all these choices with
a consistent security
and governance
framework, so whether it
is our recent launch of Cloud
Spanner Query Federation
or the launch of
autoscaling serverless Spark
Integration, which you can
learn more about in the Open
and Integrated Data
Analytics session,
or some of the new capabilities
I'm going to walk you
through now, you get
to make the choice that
is right for your business
and your data analytics needs.
Speaking of choice
of cloud, we are
very excited to announce
the general availability
of BigQuery Omni for Amazon Web
Services and Microsoft Azure.
Most companies have data
across multiple clouds today,
and that frequently
creates data silos
that make it difficult,
if not even impossible,
for analysts to access
and leverage that data.
BigQuery Omni is a flexible
cross cloud analytics solution
that lets you cost effectively
access and securely analyze
data across GCP, AWS, and Azure.
With BigQuery Omni,
you can leverage
the familiar BigQuery
UI, API, or standard SQL
to quickly answer
questions and share results
from a single pane of glass.
With net new capability
that we are announcing
called Cross Cloud Transfer,
you can use standard SQL
to bring the results of
your analysis back to GCP
with a simple copy statement
and combine that data
and perform advanced analytics
for something like BQML
or aggregate the data from
multiple clouds for Looker
and BI tools.
BigQuery Omni is serverless
and connects directly
to your data on AWS or Azure.
You can securely run analytics
on other public cloud
with a fully managed
infrastructure.
All compute runs on
BigQuery Omni clusters
in the same AWS or Azure
region as your data storage.
To learn more
about BigQuery Omni
and see a demo of our new Cross
Cloud Transfer capability,
please visit the Data Analytics
session on multi cloud,
and we encourage you
to come give it a try.
In addition to the
recent BigQuery Omni,
happy to announce that we
were making the secure lake
house architecture a reality
across all three clouds.
With the introduction of
authorized external tables,
it is now possible to have
fine-grained governance
and security permissions
on lake house data.
Authorized external tables allow
you to set up a service account
for accessing your data natively
in Google Cloud Storage, S3,
or Azure storage,
so you don't have
to grant privileges
to the raw data
or worry about
physical file layout.
You can use BigQuery's
native policy capabilities
to provide table, column,
or row-level security
for your data and data
lakes, and those policies
are consistently
enforced, regardless
of whether accessing the
data through SQL, data PROC,
or other engines, like Spark.
Net, you no longer have to care
about where your data resides
or what engine you're
using to access it in order
to provide consistent,
secure, auditable, and even
policy-driven
access to your data.
Before today, BigQuery
customers had the ability
to create user-defined
functions in SQL or JavaScript
and run them entirely
within BigQuery,
and while these functions are
performant and fully managed
from within BigQuery,
customers expressed an interest
and desire to
extend BigQuery UVFs
to their own external code.
We had requests from
health care providers
who wanted to bring
their existing security
platforms to BigQuery,
financial institutions
that wanted to
enrich their BigQuery
data with real-time
stock updates,
and data scientists who wanted
to be able to use Vertex AI
alongside with BQML.
To help these customers extend
BigQuery into other components,
we created BigQuery
External Functions.
BigQuery External Functions
provides a direct integration
with cloud functions,
GCP's serverless execution
environment for
single-purpose functions.
With external
functions in BigQuery,
you'll now be able to write a
function in node, Python, Go,
Java, .NET, Ruby, or even
PHP and execute it on columns
passed in from
BigQuery SQL queries.
BigQuery external functions that
you incorporate BigQuery SQL
functionality with software
outside of BigQuery.
We've already started
working with key partners
like Protegrity on
using external functions
as a mechanism to merge
BigQuery into their security
platform, which
will help us help
our mutual customers address
their stringent compliance
controls.
Also happy to announce the
preview of Analytics Hub, which
will help organizations publish,
discover, subscribe, and share
data assets so they can
seek broader insights
and ask bigger questions.
BigQuery has had
cross-organizational data
sharing in place
capability since inception,
and we have thousands of
organizations sharing hundreds
of petabytes of data today.
Our Analytics Hub makes
that experience of discovery
and management much easier.
Analytics Hub will
allow publishers
to create exchanges that
combine unique Google data
sets with commercial industry
data sets and public data sets.
Publishers will be able
to curate data exchanges
internally and
externally, and they'll
be able to view aggregated
usage metrics on how popular
their exchanges are.
With other interoperability
capabilities
I mentioned, it will
soon be possible to share
data in the Analytics Hub
in place from your data
to data lake, as well.
In addition to the
unique Google data
that we are working to
bring to Analytics Hub,
such as the recent release
of Google Trends data,
which enables discovery of top
search terms across locations,
we're also partnering
with Crux Informatics
to accelerate access to
data on Analytics Hub.
Data providers across finance,
geospatial, retail, and more
are all bringing
their data to BigQuery
and delivering it
through Analytics Hub.
We will announce
more partnerships
as we move closer to general
availability of Analytics Hub
next year.
Deciding to move to the
Cloud is a big commitment,
both in tech, processes,
and change management.
And knowing that it is the
right choice for your business,
both for the
capabilities it unlocks
but also for the overall
TCO, is equally important.
Happy to highlight
some capabilities
we're invested in that make
all aspects of moving your data
warehouse to the Cloud and to
BigQuery on GCP a good bet.
I'm excited to introduce
the BigQuery migration
service, a comprehensive
solution for migrating data
to BigQuery which will enable
fast and low-risk migrations.
The BigQuery migration
service speeds up
Teradata to BigQuery migrations
with predictable tooling
for customers and
partners, which
cover migration planning, data
transfer, automatic SQL script
conversion, and
data verification.
Support for additional data
warehouses is also coming soon.
One of the hardest pieces of
any data warehouse migration
is modernizing legacy business
logic like SQL queries,
scripts, and stored procedures.
The BigQuery migration
service provides
fast, semantically-correct and
human-readable translations
of legacy objects with
no ongoing dependencies.
It supports a broad range
of Teradata artifacts,
including DML, DDL, and
BTEQ, and translations
can be run in batch
mode or ad hoc directly
from the BigQuery SQL Workspace.
Customers like Walmart
and MercadoLibre
have used it to successfully
translate millions of queries,
and we encourage you
to come give a try.
When doing analytics at scale,
understanding what is happening
and being able to take action
in real time is critical,
and many of our customers also
desire capacity management
capabilities to optimize
their BQ environments.
We're happy to launch a new
BigQuery Administration Hub
experience with new
features such as research
charts and the slot estimator.
The capabilities
help our admin users
to understand and manage
their BigQuery environments
like never before.
Research charts
provide a native,
out-of-the-box experience
for real-time monitoring
and troubleshooting of
your BigQuery environments.
These charts make it
easy to understand
your historical patterns
across slot consumption, job
concurrency, and
job performance,
allowing you to take
actions to ensure
your BigQuery environment
continues to run smoothly.
This is now generally available
for all customers that
purchase slot reservations.
Many customers with
pre-purchase capacity
also want to understand,
should I buy more?
Do I have too many slots?
Will additional slots
affect my job performance?
The slot estimator is an
interactive capacity management
tool that helps administrators
estimate and optimize
their BigQuery capacity
based on jobs performance.
It looks at historical usage
and helps customers make
capacity planning decisions.
It also provides estimates
on price for performance
when adding or reducing slots.
This is now available for public
preview for all reservation
customers.
In addition to
the Admin tooling,
sometimes customers have one
off or spiking workloads,
and flex slots can
be a great solution.
In fact, many customers have
been leveraging flex slots
to scale up or down their
environments via simple SQL
statements.
This is great for
one-off batch workloads,
but does require you to estimate
and manage your capacity.
We're now happy to announce
the preview of the Flex Slot
Autoscaler.
Autoscaling enables
customers to take
full advantage of BigQuery's
elastic serverless architecture
while maintaining
controls over cost.
With autoscaling, you
simply set the size
of the environment you're
willing to scale up to
and then BigQuery looks at
your current query load.
And if more budget is
available and more capacity
would accelerate your
queries in flight,
it scales up your
environment on the fly
in very small increments.
By adjusting the size of your
environment every few seconds,
you get maximum performance
without any wasted capacity
up to your budget.
Customers like Snap
have been using
this to provide phenomenal
performance for their analysts,
and we've had customers
scale up tens of thousands
of slots for incredible
performance on really
large workloads.
In addition to the
great capabilities
we've announced for managing
your query resources,
we're also adding
additional support
for managing your storage.
Snapshots, currently
in Preview, provide
read-only, point-in-time
versions of tables
without actually having
to copy the base data
and incur duplicate costs.
They can be really useful
for logical backups,
saving the state of something
like a financial dashboard
to keep points in time,
and many other use cases.
Clones, coming soon, provide
modifiable versions of tables
without having to copy
the base data, as well.
This makes it possible
for you to test things
like schema evolution, where
you're modifying columns
for the rollout of a new
version of your application
or to set up dev test
environments that work
end-to-end so you can run
crews on a large amount of data
without incurring the
cost of duplicate data
just for a test environment.
Once you're in the
Cloud, it's time
to really leverage the
capabilities that have been
unlocked that will enable
you to drive your business
and really drive
value from that data.
Happy to highlight
some of the investments
across the full stack, from
high throughput investment to BI
in tooling and ML that will
help you unlock value from data.
For customers with needs for
real-time data analytics,
the new BigQuery Write API
is now generally available.
This new Write API underscores
our engineering innovation
to bring industry-leading
performance
for streaming ingestion.
With over 1 gigabyte
per second of ingestion
throughput enabled by
default and the ability
to scale to 100 times or more
that, the Write API allows
you to unify streaming
and batch ingestion
and offers exact once
delivery semantics.
It also supports
stream-level transactions
and automatic detection
of target schema changes.
These features, combined
with native integration
with the data flow,
will allow you
to accelerate your real-time
analytics workloads.
I'm also happy to
tell you that all
of this net new value over the
previous Streaming API, yet
is priced at 50% cheaper
than the current offerings.
So we encourage you to move
to the new BigQuery Write API.
BigQuery is a powerful
analytics engine
that provides great performance
on calculations, aggregations
for data at any scale.
However, the way
customers use BigQuery
has expanded from traditional
data warehouses or data lakes,
and today there are many
applications built on BigQuery
that may not want
to crunch numbers,
but simply return a
handful of rows associated
with a specific data point,
like a name or an IP address.
Customers expressed that when
finding these specific data
points in terabytes
or petabytes of data,
it was slower, maybe
even more cost expensive,
than the applications
were designed for.
This is because BigQuery
needs to do a full table scan
and read all of it just to
find the rows associated
with the unique element.
To help customers build these
operational applications
on top of BigQuery, we
are announcing new search
capabilities in BigQuery.
Customers can now
create Search Indexes
for a table that accelerates
the speed at which you
can identify the rows that
contain specific text.
You can use BigQuery Search
Indexes and Preview today
if you have scenarios that
would benefit from speed up
of point lookups.
Or another way,
Search Indexes are
useful when you need to
find a needle in a haystack.
Search Indexes can be used
across multiple columns
at once.
So even if you don't know
exactly where the data is
stored, it can still be found.
It's also fully integrated
with our native JSON data type,
also in Preview,
meaning that you
can search for fields
and values in data
that is unstructured or has a
constantly changing structure.
These search indexes also
back our new log analytics
application that was
recently announced,
Cloud Logging, which helps use
BigQuery to better understand
your telemetry and data.
Like the rest of BigQuery,
these search indexes
are fully managed
and serverless.
Google has all the
resource provisioning,
tokenizes the data, and loads
the index behind the scenes.
So once you create a
Search Index on a table,
you can start streaming data
in and know that your search
indexes will
automatically be refreshed
without any management overhead.
We've been working
with our customers
on this feature, who
started testing it
for a variety of
different use cases.
For example, a
major retailer found
that they are
improving dashboards
that have highly
selective inventory items
that they need to
slice and dice.
We've also worked for
several companies in the U
who are hoping use Search
Indexes to dramatically reduce
costs for their GDPR
processes, since they're now
able to touch only the rows that
contain specific individuals,
no longer having to
query the full data set
for each GDPR request.
And of course, we found a
myriad of other improvements
for log analytics
applications that
can now use BigQuery for
efficient lookups of things
like IP addresses, error
codes, emails, and URLs.
We were one of the first
to bring integrated
machine learning into the data
warehouse with BigQuery ML,
and we continue to see
tremendous adoption
and customer innovation
because of the ease of use,
ability to unlock ML with
only a few lines of SQL,
and no infrastructure
management.
In addition to continued
investment in additional models
and capabilities, like
XG Boost, AutoML Tables,
and Hyperparameter
Tuning, I wanted
to highlight our work
around a couple of areas.
First off, Explainable AI.
Explainable AI helps you
understand the results
that your predictive
machine learning models
generate by defining how
much each feature contributes
to the predicted results.
This is referred to as
feature attribution.
This information can be used
to verify the model as behaving
as expected, to recognize
bias in your models,
and to inform ways
to improve your model
and your training data.
We support both local and
global explainability.
We're also investing in
integrating BQML and Vertex AI
closer together so you can
leverage the best of both
for ML ops deployments.
For example, BQML models
will be registered in Vertex
and they can be used to manage
versions and compare there.
We'll also be adding
support in Vertex Pipelines.
So all BQML training
and prediction
will be possible through
Vertex pipeline components.
So this user can continue to
use their favorite notebook
and use BQML pipeline
components to vote, training,
and prediction.
Overall, in partnership
with the Vertex AI team,
we're committed to delivering
a powerful and fully integrated
ML solution with
great ease of use.
Finally, happy to announce
the launch of BigQuery's
BI Engine, our solution for
enabling data and business
analysts to perform interactive
analytics in real-time
and with high concurrency.
BI Engine is not a cache.
It is a fully-distributed,
highly-available, in-memory
database Engine, which
is natively incorporated
into standard BigQuery APIs.
It enables subsequent
queries on large data
sets with high concurrency
and can eliminate the need
to manage BI servers
or ETL pipelines,
and it natively works with SQL
and BI tools such as Looker,
Tableau, Power BI, et cetera.
For GA, we added support for
pinning preferred tables and up
to one terabyte of
memory per reservation
and additional joint operations
and support for streaming.
This means that in
combination with the new Write
API for high
throughput streaming,
materialized views which have
also been recently released,
and BI Engine for acceleration
of interactive analytics,
these technologies
all work together
to make the vision of always
fresh, always fast analytics
a reality at any scale.
That was quite
the whirlwind tour
of what's new with BigQuery.
Thank you for joining
us today, and I
hope you can see our
commitment to provide
powerful analytic
solutions that will
help drive your businesses
forward and help you unlock
data.
If you'd like to
learn more, here
are some additional
sessions I suggest
you take a look at to see
the power of Omni, Serverless
Spark, Streaming, Log Analytics,
and Secure Data Classification
with Google Cloud.
Thanks again for joining me
to learn more about BigQuery,
and I hope we can help you
drive your business and data
analytics for your
company forward.
Thank you.